microplastic microplastics microplastics
are those small often toxic particles
that are the result of degrading plastic
or consumer product this is what I found
in a cheap can of tuna when I looked at
it under the microscope I found what
appeared to be
microplastic the question is what would
this potentially do to my health do they
contain cancer causing agents or maybe
they cause
inflammation National chains like
McDonald's Domino's and chipotle all
have something in common according to
new research potentially dangerous
chemicals found in the food Dr laia
Edwards is the lead researcher of the
study that analyzed fast food finding
thades and other plasticizers leeching
into the food we eat the chemicals are
used to make plastic soft for food
packaging processing equipment and
handling gloves many Studies have
demonstrated how microplastics make
their way into our bodies through food
and water however research researchers
say microplastics are even tiny enough
to enter the bronchioles and get trapped
in different parts of the airway
branches some numbers show humans could
be inhaling the equivalent of an entire
credit card's worth of plastic within a
week researchers affiliated with the
journalism organization or media tested
nearly a dozen brands of water purchased
in countries around the world and they
found some disquieting things so what
they did is they went to a number of
countri R Asia North America South
America Europe and and they pulled
bottled water that was available on the
shelves and sent it to a lab in New York
had it tested and they were looking for
microplastics those are extremely tiny
pieces pieces of plastic the the
thickness of a human hair and in many
cases they found them in fact in
93% of the bottles that were tested
brands that you know Aquafina danan
Nestle you know the list goes on interal
Brands not any brand in particular not
yeah all sorts of brands in 93% of the
bottles they tested they found these
microplastics they're absolutely
everywhere we've got this growing
evidence that the microplastic is a
problem that not very much have been
done to look at Solutions at the what do
we do about it we need to start to take
action since the invention of plastic in
1907 nearly every single piece of
plastic that's ever been created is
still somewhere on Earth floating in the
ocean lying on the seabed buried on the
ground or piled high in a landfill and
sure it might be bad for sea turtles but
it's also extremely bad for you because
of one thing microplastics see Plastics
may not be biodegradable but that
doesn't mean they don't break down at
all over time plastic in the ocean
breaks down into hundreds of thousands
of tiny microscopic pieces called
microplastics and these microplastics do
not just stay in the ocean they get into
everything bottled water Seafood salt
beer even the air we breathe in a study
where they investigated the indoor air
quality of three Apartments they found
all of them to be contaminated with
microplastics in the air and they
estimate that the average human inhales
a credit card's worth of microplastics
every single week and these
microplastics have been linked to a long
list of health issues including insulin
resistance reproductive problems cancer
unexplainable waking metabolic disorders
and neurotoxicity or in other words
they're linked to all the common
problems we see in America today but
what's scary is that there's literally
no way to avoid them even if the whole
world stop producing plastic right now
there are already more than 8 billion
tons of plastic in the world that's
enough to fill 55 million jumbo Jets so
plastic is not going anywhere anytime
soon and there's currently no safe way
to get rid of it burning it releases a
massive amount of microplastics and
harmful chemicals into the air bearing
it helps it break down faster and
dumping it into the ocean well that is
what got us into this mess in the first
place and if you're thinking why can't
we just recycle it isn't that the green
thing to do well you are sadly
mistaken
[Music]
on the surface microplastics seem gross
but harmless I mean come on most of the
plastic we eat or drink will eventually
pass through our system right so what is
the harm well there are many super small
pieces of microplastic or microplastic
with sharp edges can actually cause
damage to our lungs and organs but on
top of that the real danger are in the
chemicals that make up plastic plastic
is one of the the most versatile
products on Earth it's flexible it's
bendable it comes on all shapes and
sizes but to get all these variations
plastic manufacturers need to add a long
list of chemicals to their products as
it stands there are more than 10,000 of
these chemicals for manufacturers to
choose from these 10,000 chemicals are
what make plastic straws bendy and
plastic toys hard and durable they are
what give plastic all those bright
colors the problem is most of these
cheap useful chemicals that make plastic
great or also absolutely terrible for
the human body when we consume or inhale
microplastics we're not just taking in
the plastic we're also taking in all
these chemicals used to make the plastic
as well out of the 10,000 plastic
additives commonly used by manufacturers
well then 2,400 of them are potentially
dangerous some of these additives are
better known than others for example BPA
BPA was one of the biggest plastic
additives in water bottles and food
packaging until people realize that it
seriously damages your reproductive
system along with your bone desity and
neural development BPA also mimics the
hormone estrogen and men that means a
drop in sperm count sex drive and an
increase in erectile dysfunction BPA is
also linked to a variety of cancers ADHD
and obesity the Cincinnati Cancer Center
has found that levels of BPA in men's
urine can be a sign of prostate cancer
bisphenol a or BPA is an environmental
pollutant used to make the hard clear
plastic found in many food containers so
when plastic manufacturers started
producing BPA free plastic everyone
thought the Panic was over but BPA was
just one of those 2,400 toxic additiv in
plastic what about the other
2399 BPA ended up being replaced with
BPF and BPS which surprise surprise
those new chemicals are now found to be
probably just as bad as BPA the reality
is though BPA got a bad R and so
manufacturers seized on this and they
said well I'm going to sell BPA free
everything they didn't just take out BPA
they took out BPA but they replaced it
with its chemical cousin BPS or
bisphenol S sure enough the
toxicological profile looks exactly the
same darn near similar to BPA so in that
way they played a game with he was
consumer BPA free is great that label
might as well say contains BPS BPS is
starting to get a bad WP you know what
the replacement is BPF this goes on and
on but it's not just the chemicals that
are dangerous microplastic can also pick
up all sorts of terrible stuff before
ending up in your body qu when they're
in an environment they basically suck up
chemicals like a sponge things like
pesticides fluorinated compounds flame
retardants and so on End quotes and once
the microplastic carrying these
chemicals get into your body they
release them and the results can be
devastating cancer chronic inflammation
and a long list of unknown diseases and
conditions are probably caused in part
by the microplastics in our bodies even
viruses and bacteria can hit a ride on
microplastics so what are some things
you can do right now to reduce your
[Music]
exposure if you're still using a plastic
cutting board or plastic kitchen
utensils like a spatula now is a good
time to throw all of it away and off for
wooden or stainless steel versions
another thing you can swap out right now
are plastic bottles and in general you
want to see what products you're in
contact with on a daily basic that are
plastic and replace them seriously throw
out the cutting board right now unless
you want to be eating 7 to 50 g of
microplastics from it quote on the upper
end of the scale plastic board shed the
equivalent to the mass of 10 red Solo
cups worth of microplastics over the
course of a year end quotes but let's
say you don't use any plastic at all
even that won't keep you safe most
plastic ends up being dumped into a
landfill or the ocean we're talking
paint clothes made from synthetic fabric
car tires beauty products shower gels
exfoliants tea bags and even fishing
nets all these things were constantly
giving off more and more microplastics
into the environments it's gone so bad
that up to 12% of the dust in American
Homes just regular old dust is actually
made up of microplastics they've even
found microplastics in human breast milk
scientists have even recorded huge
amounts of microplastics falling from
the sky in the mountains of Southern
France more than 60 mil from the nearest
city and as we mentioned before all the
plastic that we've ever produced and
will produce is here to stay so unless
we want to breathe in even more
microplastics as the years go on we need
to recycle more plastic we need to reuse
more plastic so it doesn't end up in
landfills or the ocean where it breaks
down the problem is recycling as it
stands today is pretty much a
[Music]
sham reduce reuse recycle
it's worth it it is worth it only 9% of
the plastic you recycle ever gets
recycled this is because recycling as it
stands today is an extremely complicated
process and we're really Limited in what
we can recycle with traditional
recycling you have to build a giant
recycling plant that already takes up a
ton of time and money then you're only
able to recycle a tiny amount of the
plastic waste out there which means
you're going to have to spend a ton of
effort sorting through all the plastic
on top of that if the plastic is too
dirty and contaminated it can't be
recycled so then you have to wash the
plastic all of this makes recycling
extremely expensive to make things even
worse plastic is made from many complex
materials just processing all together
is a very challenging job so it carries
a lot of negative cost because we have
to clean it sort it wash it and only
later process it not many people think
of washing yogurt containers oil cans
shampoo bottle or ketchup bottle before
disposing them in the recycle bin and
that is why only 9% of plastic is
recycled which leaves the other 91% to
go into dumps be incinerated or it ends
up in the ocean where it breaks down
into microplastics we desperately need a
better way to recycle one that can
tolerate more contamination that
requires less sorting and washing and
that is way cheaper and one company
working on the solution is called aural
clean Technologies and what they're
doing is super unique instead of
focusing on the tiny amount of plastics
that are recyclable today aduro is
targeting the harder to recycle Plastics
and they're doing this with a brand new
patented chemical based approach this
new chemical based approach can be used
on way more different types of plastics
while being able to put up with more
contamination on top of that their Tech
operates at lower temperatures which
means lower operating costs while also
increasing how much plastic they can
recycle all of this means that recycling
can be way more profitable while
reducing microplastics the way it worse
is that you get plastic waste you crush
it into simple granules with minimum
sorting and washing and then those
granules are fed into a reactor system
that breaks down the plastic strong
molecular chains into hydrocarbon
molecules and boom just like that you
turn otherwise useless toxic plastic
waste into high value oil that can be
used as raw material for new Plastics to
make new products or you can even turn
it into higher value fuel think of
ador's method as kind of like reversing
plastic back into the petrochemicals it
was originally made from so just imagine
what would happen if corporations are
actually going to be able to make money
from recycling well they're definitely
not going to let that plastic gold go to
waste in the ocean or landfills anymore
and what's cool is that this is not
theory adoro has been working on this
for more than 11 years they've already
proven this method works in the lab and
now they're working on building their
first pilot project this year and they
not going to be holding this Tech back
just for themselves either once they're
up and running their hope is to license
this new recycling method out that way
if other corporations want to get in on
this to make money they can their idea
is that the more companies that are
using their Tech the better it is for
all of us and it would allow aduro to
hopefully scale way bigger way faster
compared to if they were to run the
recycling plants themselves think of
this as kind of like the McDonald's
business model but for this new way of
recycling aduro wanted to be the paid
sponsor of this video to help get the
word out and to let you know that aduro
is a public company listed on the stock
markets so if you think what they're
doing is cool and you want to support
them you can check them out by scrolling
down and clicking the link below scroll
down and click the link below now full
disclaimer and disclosures are linked
down there as well stay dangerous and
we'll see you in the next
[Music]
one